pitch perfect 2 you were nervous about
doing the first pitch perfect you
weren't sure that this was a good career
move for you
yeah i was convinced it was going to be
my geely uh i was like
i was like out of the gate i don't know
a a teen singing a cappella movie is the
is the way to go right following
workaholics i didn't know if the fans
would follow but
it turned out to be super funny and i
think i think
the number one movie of all time i think
was the stat on it
i'm not what are you laughing that's a
real stat you know we had uh jeremy
renner on
i gotta say it was a week ago yesterday
memory serves right
yeah i think that avengers movie you saw
that episode it's a good one
uh best crab we've had in a while and
they
they saw them
they uh that movie i think might be uh
i don't know we'll check the numbers but
i doubt it okay
uh but you know what you were were you
nervous about you nervous about the fact
that you had to sing
yeah well i i'm not a singer so i didn't
i was convinced that they were just
gonna
replace me with like sam smith or
someone
i mean or just put someone else's voice
just yeah in my mouth
oh oh yeah uh-huh uh just have adele
come out and just i'm super british the
whole time
as you can tell i'm great with
impressions yeah i'm so good i'm super
british
[Laughter]
um we're having fun and that's the most
important part
i don't know why i don't know why i
injected you with a pencil and
i will get injected with your heroin
lead did you
did you get a vocal coach because that's
a big thing you go if you're going to be
some singing you've got to do some
really i i yeah i request i requested
one and i was like you got to hook me up
because these pipes are a little
rusty and they said no
they said hard pass we don't care about
you right um
and so so i i had to do my own i i ended
up
because you know i drink a lot and so
uh the second movie i started to sound
like tom waits you know i was uh
yeah i showed up on set i'm like i'm
ready to go and they're like oh god
um but i would do my own vocal warm-ups
that i learned in
in high school like during drama and
stuff they teach you stuff
you remember those the double bubble
triple bubble gum yum yum
evidently i'm british also 100 finished
there too
bubblegum
[Applause]
red leather yellow leather what red
leather yellow leather yeah
red leather yellow leather it's just
enunciation
red leather the way you said what i
thought you're going to hit me
physical of the host i'm the most
physical and violent
yeah i've known that about you that's my
that's my claim to fame at late night
television yeah you never know when i'm
just going to go ape [ __ ]
and rip your face that's why i like you
so much you're like my dad
you